it was about this time last year when
Junkin made it a point to listen to
parents and eventually took their
concerns straight to the governor's
mansion and this time around many of
those same issues are clearly on voters
Minds
the economy definitely is the issue
between inflation with every like prices
of everything going up especially rent
and gas Reproductive Rights is like my
top issue the big thing is the Border
policy all right that's awful I think
there needs to be a Crackdown on crime
our educational assist with the kind of
education problems that we're having the
focus which seems to be on far more than
what it should be it's not on the usual
Reading Writing arithmetic even more
worried about these young families how
can they afford to have the gas what it
is and and the price of meat the food
suspenser the rain Con Edison everything
is going crazy I'm very little stressed
out
really is an issue that cuts across
America let's go right to Republican
Virginia governor Glenn Yankee Governor
good to spend some time with you I want
to start off by saying that Democrats
had been closing the Gap in the generic
preference poll but Republicans seem to
have found some new momentum in recent
days this new commitment to America that
Kevin McCarthy unveiled last week do you
believe that is the prescription for
victory for the Republicans in November
I I do believe that we need to focus on
Common Sense solutions to these kitchen
table issues that voters Across America
are expressing very clearly as you just
as you just shared in fact we saw it in
Virginia last year where of course the
the the Democrat uh want to talk about
things that really aren't what's
affecting people every day and it is
inflation and cost of living it's crime
it's education it's the reality that the
border is a national security crisis
that's impacting all states Virginia is
a border state because of the fentanyl
overdoses that we're dealing with these
are these are the most important issues
that I think the Republican candidates
are showing that we have common sense
solutions to and as I've traveled around
the nation and had a chance to visit
with Republican governor candidates what
we're also able to demonstrate is that
States run by Republican Governors have
outperformed States run by Democrat
governors in an extraordinary rate
Economic Development out outcomes in
schools small business growth I mean the
reality of course is that even a state
like Virginia where under the previous
Democrat leadership there were 47th in
the nation in job recovery coming out of
the pandemic and now in the last eight
months we've actually rocketed up into a
top 20 State and job recovery this is
all about common sense solutions to
these most important issues so somebody
ask you this question because you said
that this what's important are issues
that people deal with on a day-to-day
basis the Democrats would argue that
abortion is an issue that many women in
America deal with on a day-to-day basis
and it is incredibly important issue for
them let's put up on the screen latest
Washington Post ABC News poll how
Republicans and Democrats fare against
each other on all these issues the
economy Republicans with a clear lead
inflation Republicans with a clear lead
abortion it flips around the Democrats
have got about the same percentage and
then it goes on down through crime
education schools climate change and
immigration Republicans need to make
this election about bread and butter
issues because the abortion message from
the Democrats is what closed the Gap
over the long summer holiday what what
can the Republicans do in the next six
weeks to try to stretch that lead back
out again I mean it was it was it was a
bloodbath for the for the Republicans
against the Democrats until that dots
decision came out
well let me begin with the fact that
even in my election last year my
opponent tried to make the entire
election about abortion and of course
it's not something that I shied away
from I mean Virginians elected a
pro-life Governor last year of course
the reality is that is that my opponent
and the left liberal Democrats are the
ones with the extreme views it is
Extreme to promote abortion all the way
up through and including birth paid for
with taxpayer money and Virginians
expressed one clear desire to have fewer
abortions as opposed to more and that's
the idea that abortions would be
available all the way up through birth
was Radical and I think Americans
believe that as well and I think that's
the message that Republican candidates
need to carry clearly you're 100 right
as we head into the this November the
8th election and oh by the way in
Virginia we're already in early voting
voters are really focusing on those
issues that they care most about and of
course Paco book issues and runaway
inflation that really represents the
failed Biden presidency when it comes to
managing our economy crime which
represents the the fundamental belief
from Progressive liberals that you bring
fewer resources as opposed to more
resources and guess what crime goes up
and education in education as everyone
is now back in school is taking its
rightful place as a top issue we saw it
in Virginia and let's just be clear
parents matter this is not a Republican
versus Democrat issue this is a parent
issue and I think we'll continue to see
education play a huge role in the
outcome of this election Governor let me
come back to Crime which you mentioned
just a moment ago uh my colleague Katie
Pavlich one of her favorite things to do
is go on the next door app and check on
what's going on with crime in her
neighborhood and then when you listen to
the far left Democrats this is what
they're saying about crime listen here
defunding the police has to happen we
need to defund the police yes I support
the defund movement talking about
um the reduction of our NYPD budget and
defunding a six billion NYPD budget not
only do we need to defund but we need to
dismantle now that was the far left of
the left there's no question about that
President Biden has tried to come out
and say no I'm not for defunding the
police I'm for funding the police but do
they basically own what the members of
the squad said
I think they have to and the reality
when we speak with Community leaders in
commit in communities that are really
suffering a dramatic escalation in
violent crimes is they want more police
on the street they want more prosecutors
in order to keep people in jail and oh
by the way they would like more
activities for their children so that
their kids have positive things to do
and those are the kinds of things we're
pressing forward with in Virginia but by
the way the bottom line is we see a
dramatic gap between full Staffing and
current Staffing in almost every police
agency and this has to be the primary
goal is to re-establish full Staffing
and full funding for training and
equipment and personnel and that's got
to be our first step in making
communities safer and that's what we're
doing in Virginia so like all polls this
ABC News Washington Post poll uh was a
bit of a popularity contest as well
Biden's approval rating in this poll is
at 39 percent his disapproval rating is
at 53 percent and Biden has in the past
inextricably linked himself to the
Democratic party listen to how he put it
I am the Democratic party right now the
platform of the democratic department is
what I in fact approved of
poll numbers that's the sort of thing
that Republicans could put on a loop
and I think the Republicans are I mean
the reality is that we're gonna we're
gonna see Joe Biden's uh uh perception
from voters reflected in how they vote
and let's just be real inflation's at a
40-year high we're seeing the economy
all of a sudden be forcibly stalled in
order to combat it we've got challenges
in our schools where we've had dramatic
learning losses and kids have suffered
because of unforced shuttering of
schools by democrats all over the nation
we're seeing high crime and oh by the
way voters are asking one basic question
which is why would I support any of that
when in fact there are common sense
solutions to all of these issues and
that's what Republican Governors have
demonstrated that they're doing and oh
by the way that's where our Republican
congressional candidates and Senate
candidates are in fact promising that
they are going to stand up and press
forward with so so the the uh former
press secretary for president bud
jensaki has become uh remarkably candid
since she left the White House she was
on Meet the Press yesterday saying here
is the choice that voters have and
here's what it means for Democrats
listen to how she put it
if the election is about who is the most
extreme
um as we saw you know Kevin McCarthy
touch on there with Marjorie Taylor
green I'll say her name sitting over his
left side then they're going to win if
it is a referendum on the president they
will lose
so you are a candidate who was known as
a trump candidate you tacked hard toward
the middle to make sure that you didn't
alienate all of those moderate voters
and you won election in part two because
Terry McAuliffe really put not just one
foot in his mouth but both of them uh
all all the way down to his his stomach
but
what do you say to some of these
candidates out there in the Republican
Party who to many people do look like
they're on the extreme end of things
I first say that candidates need to
recognize that they have to stay true to
who they are
and that's one of the things that I was
able to do last year is establish a
platform and run consistently on it for
the entire campaign and then oh by the
way deliver on it when I was elected I
also think it's really important for
candidates to recognize that this is not
an or moment it's an and moment we
brought together forever trumpers and
never trumpers we brought together tea
party members and Libertarians and
moderates and a lot of Democrats not
because we said anything different but
because we fully engaged with these
Common Sense solutions to these critical
issues people want candidates and they
want elected officials who represent
getting things done and I think that the
the success that we've had in Virginia
and translating a campaign platform into
real success I think only furthers the
idea that Common Sense Solutions are
ones people can believe in and that's
what Republicans are running on this
year Governor we should point out you're
at uh G3 Community Services which is a
charity which works towards
strengthening the family you have made
it a point as Virginia governor because
you're one of those fortunate people who
doesn't need to take your gubernatorial
salary uh you have been donating your
salary to various causes back in the
first quarter you donated to First
Responders counseling you donated to a
veterans Group after that why did you
choose this particular group to donate
your quarter salary to
well g-cube represents exactly what we
think the future of Education needs to
reflect the ability to have community
non-profits and along with business
interests working with the public school
system to provide to provide alternative
tracks and what of course gcube does is
provide computer science training and
coaching and oh by the way credentials
and everything from core coding all the
way through to virtual reality and here
we have public school kids across the
entire School District able to
participate and to chart a different
path and maybe they'll go to work right
away maybe they won't need to go to
college and incur 70 or 80 000 in debt
maybe they can in fact stack their
education along the way with a great
employer but this is the future of
Virginia's education which is multiple
Pathways for kids with computer science
being a very important one
Governor Glenn young good to spend some
time with you thanks very much for the
spending uh some time with us this
Monday afternoon appreciate it
always always great to be with you and I
appreciate you letting me join you all
right thank you we'll see you again soon
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else